Today I am really pleased to have with
me Stu Jay Raj, who is a person that,
uh, in the polyglot sphere somebody
that I've been following for it must
be it's certainly more than 10 years.
I don't know how many years.
And I've seen him and he excels
in languages that I don't know
anything about like Southeast Asian
languages, South Asian languages.
So without further ado, Stu can you tell
us a little about what you do, where you
live, and, uh, what your various, uh,
you know, activities are on the internet?
So thank you, Steve.
It's an honor to, um, to be here
with you and a long time coming.
Uh, first of all, my name, so Stu Jay
Raj, that's the Indian part of me.
Raj?
Yes.
Um, but that's cool.
You can call me what you want.
Um, I, most people in this part of the
world know me as my middle name, Jay.
It's a lot easier in Thai and
it actually flows well in Thai.
The other thing is...
sounds like , which sounds like
cockroach, which is also a pimp in Thai.
So my name in this part of the
world, everyone knows me as Jay,
everyone else, Stu, and very few
as Raj and my Chinese name...
so depends what you want to call me.
So, um, yeah, I've been here
in, uh, my base is Thailand
here for over 20 years now.
Um, before that Indonesia
originally from Austria.
Uh, I grew up speaking
a bunch of languages.
My grandfather was a polyglot.
He spoke my, so my white grandfather
on my mom's side, um, he spoke
Chinese, Japanese, Hebrew,
Russian, French, Italian, Latin,
and a bunch of other languages.
And so as a kid, we grew up playing
with language and sound and Morse
code and listening to shortwave radio.
And it just grew from there.
And so as I grew up, I also had a
surrogate family was Indonesian.
So I grew up speaking Indonesian and then
Chinese, they were Chinese Indonesians.
So from my grandfather, both Chinese
and then the, um, Indonesian side, they
also speak Chinese and it grew up our
base language at home here is Thai.
Um, and then around in my work, basically
I work with companies, uh, around
the world, governments in aerospace,
oil and gas, modern trade, a bunch of
different industries where language is
just a tool to get other things done.
So it's building communication
channels, making deals.
And for me language is, um, a thing
that gives me an edge, especially
in this region and with this looking
face, um, you're able to speak with
Western clients as one of them.
But then also speak with people
on the ground and get them
to open up as one of them.
And so that's where,
that's where I'm from.
I guess the languages that I use
the most, uh, Thai, Indonesian,
Mandarin, actually surprisingly
Danish, um, Spanish, um, and then
other languages from around the region.
I thought Danish was an
Asian language actually.
Yeah, actually it is.
You'd be surprised how
many Scandinavians...
No, just to listen to it.
Yeah.
Yeah....
So, and you, do you have like a
YouTube channel or a blog or anything?
Yeah.
So actually, if you go to, um, anything
Stu Jay so Minecraft, so my blog, if
you do a YouTube search on Stu Jay,
Stewart Jay so Stu Jay, you will find me
otherwise go to Mindkraft that's with a K.
So M I N D K R A F T.Me.
And I've been migrating everything into
that because this is the latest project
that I've done, um, from this year, which
will hopefully keep growing out, which is
consolidating everything from language,
from tech and just the brain and learning.
And we have a huge community there.
So mindkraft.me is like
the portal into that.
Jay academy is my, um,
platform J C A D E M Y.com.
Uh, but they, they sort of host the
content of Mindkraft and other stuff.
And then we have a great Discord
server, but it's all my Mindkraft
of me would be a first port of call.
Hmm.
So we'll leave that information
with links in the description box.
Now, first question is which
languages, in fact, do you speak?
Um, as, as you know, there's a big
gradient, the languages that I speak
regularly and that I, uh, let's,
let's start with the languages that I
facilitate training and do work in and
do business in regularly, uh, Indonesian
and Malaysian, of course, Thai, Lao
and, and anything, I guess, from these
Thai gradient of languages, um, Chinese.
So Mandarin Cantonese, uh, too, when
I'm in Hong Kong, I'll use Cantonese,
uh, quite a bit, but my Mandarin is much
more strong, stronger than my Cantonese.
Um, then we go down to like Vietnamese,
Burmese, which talking about this part
of the world, Vietnamese, Burmese, I
will use them when I need to go down
and speak to people and get things done.
However, say my Vietnamese and
Burmese wouldn't be at the level
where I'd facilitate full classes yet.
Um, possibly soon but not yet.
Um, then I also actually
use Spanish a lot.
I, during my, um, university years, Uh, I
shifted my Italian, which my grandfather
used to speak with me to, into Spanish.
And, um, I also play jazz.
So I played with a bunch of
Latino musicians as well, for many
years in university and dated a
Chilean woman for four years, so
that got my Spanish up to par.
Um, Danish, of course,
and Swedish and Norwegian.
I'll put those in there.
When I'm in Sweden and Norway...
Why the Scandinavian?
At school, there was surprisingly a
big community of exchange students,
both of my friends who would go
and live in Scandinavian countries
and Scandinavian students that
came and um, went to our school.
And so there were a bunch of us that just
spoke Scandinavian languages together.
And then, so I got the bug.
And so as a young kid, I actually then
took it off my bat to go in and I think
I've told this story in other places,
but basically I looked up Scandinavian
surnames in the, uh, then white pages and
yellow pages for Scandinavian restaurants.
I tracked out where in Sydney they were,
and I went door knocking and I found
a Scandinavian community and it just
happened that Danish was the predominant
one there where I found, and I really
just immersed myself in Danish and
ended up in book clubs and everything
as a young kid, um, to the point that
I actually got quite fluent back then,
uh, into my teenagerdom with Danish.
You know, if anybody wants to get a
Danish experience, they should look
up the seaside hotel in Netflix.
Oh, really?
The series it's phenomenal, phenomenal.
All in Danish.
It's a love, it's a lot, very,
a lot of fun, just a lot of fun.
The Seaside Hotel or Beach  Hotel.
I can't remember what it's
called, but something like that.
I put a clip out recently where I
spoke Danish, but if I were to do it
all again, knowing what I know now and
having traveled through also Norway and
Sweden, I think I would have learned
Norwegian first, um, because Danish
has had a long lasting impression on my
throat which is really hard to kick when
you're speaking Swedish and Norwegian.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
So one question comes to mind, like
people have stereotypes, uh, you know,
they, it's not unusual to see an Asian
looking person speak, uh, Aussie English
with an Aussie accent or, uh, you
know, American English or even Scottish
or whatever, you know, that's just a
given, but when you see someone who
doesn't look Thai or Laotian or, uh,
you know, Vietnamese, even Chinese.
Like what do you think is more
difficult for a, uh, say a European
language native speaker to learn those
languages that seem exotic to us, or
is it easier for those people to learn
what is probably to them a more exotic
language, English or French or Spanish?
Um...
Which way is it?
I think it's expected in the
west that anyone going there
will learn the language.
If they're living in the country
over here, you get what's called
these ex-pat bubbles, I guess.
And which, you know, what's the difference
between an ex-pat and an immigrant?
Um, but these ex-pat bubbles where
people live 20, 30 years without having
to speak a word of the local language.
So this has becomes a normal, um,
what I have found, however, and since
day one, because I knew a lot of
languages that feed into Thai as well
as like old Chinese, middle Chinese.
And then, um, from my dad's side, so
Hindi and Sanskrit and other Indic
languages, Thai was actually quite
easy, um, to, to get up to speed.
I could write it in an afternoon
from my understanding of
Devanagari, um, and Sanskrit.
And so within months I
was up speaking Thai.
And the thing that I find is, it's not
difficult, but you just have to get beyond
that, but it's understanding the system
and it is that system that's based on...
and even Chinese is based on, I dunno if
you've ever looked at their ... system
in Chinese, but this is also based
on the map of the human mouth,
which is the Devanagari or Sanskrit.
Uh Brahmic, um, And so
everything from tones...
tones in Mandarin, a parallel one-to-one
in these boxes that you have Thai
tones and Vietnamese and anything,
um, is actually based on this map,
which is traced back to Sanskrit.
Believe it or not, even the
Korean writing is based on
this same format from Sanskrit.
So having that, it's not a hard jump,
but if you're going into Thai say as your
first Asian language and not having that
backup, it is like, what the heck is this?
Because most native speakers of Thai don't
actually understand the system because the
native speakers, nobody ever taught them.
Right.
And even in the schools.
And so the way they learn is by
rote and just by memorizing rules,
that seemingly don't make sense.
So that is a huge challenge, but actually
Thai is not a difficult language to,
to learn and to develop prosody in.
And this is the key I think,
is developing this process.
And prosody always trumps what
you look like on the outside.
If I go into a Seven Eleven and
I can speak in a way that feels
natural, um, they will instantly
just speak to me normally.
And there are some tricks that
you can throw some cues in.
Um, that will, uh, for example,
if you go in, um ... you don't
need to put that in a plastic bag.
And the way that I say that is a
colloquial way that anyone else
would say it and they might even be
looking at your face and then the
whole interaction will just be in Thai
and go without any surprise at all.
There, there is a tendency for
them to speak to you in English,
as soon as they look at you?
Yes, so this gets back
to then your question.
The big challenge is, and most poeple
say oh they won't speak Thai to me.
Um, or they just won't
speak Chinese to me.
Maybe you've had that where people
will just speak English to you.
And so that is one of
the biggest challenges.
Yeah.
I found that to be a function of
how well you speak the language.
I never get that in Chinese.
I never get it in Japanese.
I shouldn't say never, but very rarely.
Yeah.
I agree.
Um, you know, if the person assumes
that you speak their language better
than they speak your language, they'll
happily, most people are happy to use
the language that makes the most sense.
Uh, let me ask you a question,
what advice now, so a lot of those
languages are, uh, so someone who
wants to learn a tonal language,
whether it be Mandarin or Cantonese
or, uh, you know, Thai or whatever,
Burmese is tonal as well, isn't it?
Yeah
Yeah.
So, and, and presumably they're
not going to learn the Sanskrit,
uh, rules or whatever it was.
Uh, what sort of general bits of
advice do you have for people?
Presumably you just said, they're not
going to learn the sanscript rules.
Um, I that's why I've set Mindkraft up.
Actually, you're insane not
to learn the Sanskrit rules.
Okay.
Um, because, and this is the other thing
tones in English, we think of tones.
The word tone has a
connotation with pitch.
Tones are not pitch.
And I will say that again, tones
are not pitch, tones are throat.
And the pitch is a
by-product of the throat.
So you, and you get these people
learning tonal languages and they'll
leave and get these graphs and try
and plot the frequencies of their
actual pitch to match native speakers.
And they still get the tone wrong.
They still get the confused looks on
the face and it's especially apparent
in Vietnamese because tones are a whole
bunch of different things that are going
on in the throat, which are actually
traced back to that Sanskrit map.
It's not a difficult map.
You've got...
Was Sanskrit a tonal language?
Um, no, it wasn't.
Well, you actually had pitches, so
similar to pitch, actually accent.
However, the it's, this is
the whole thing, because tones
are not pitches in English.
We use this stupid word tone,
which forces everybody to focus
on something to do with pitch.
And it's not, you focus on the throat.
And so if I say like
I've got normal voice...
you see the voices, just...
and it glides off.
And then I've got stiff voice...
my voice cuts it.
And then I've got creaky voice...
where it ratchets down at the end.
They are the only three tones
originally in any tonal language,
whether it's Burmese, whether it's
Chinese, whether the Vietnamese,
whether it's Thai, Thai languages.
And then you've got registers.
So you've got breathy voice.
So aspirate, so ... you've got, um,
voices that where the glottis is closed
in the beginning ... and then you've got
voiced ... And so between these three
and then those, um, different, um, What
I, what I just mentioned then about
the stiff voice, normal voice and the
creaky voice that makes a matrix of nine.
And then you have, um,
whether it's dead at the end.
So ... versus ... that T K
P at the end, we'll kill it.
And so you've got short and
long vowels then with those.
And so you'll have a three by five grid
and this three by five grid maps to every
single tonal language in the region.
Vietnamese, Chinese, Cantonese,
Hochin um, Thai, every Thai dialect.
These are called Gedney boxes.
Google Gedneyboxes.
G E D N E Y.
And so these Gedney boxes are based
on what's going on in the mouth.
And the pitch then is just a by-product,
but you don't have to get the actual
pitch contours exact because actually the
pitches change depending what's around
them, but getting the throat right...
so you would know in Chinese, if
you've got two number three tones,
So .... So number three tone is learnt
as ... by learners of, of Chinese.
And so they will try and pronounce that
... perfectly every time they see a number
three tone, but it's not ... so the,
the ... the throat is actually closing
up and pulling it up, which is where
the rising tone originally came from.
The ... was the throat closing with a
glottal stop at the end ... is because
you're getting this glottal stop, not
having to finish all the way, because
it's at that bottom arc of the third tone.
And so Chinese learners will go
in and learn all of these rules,
how these all clip together.
But if you just memorize this grid and
memorize and get the throat actions
correct, you'll find that all of these
... and all of these rules based around the
tones, actually just come out in the wash.
And you'll sound very natural.
And so this is what I do.
I actually teach people whether they're
learning Sanskrit or not, how to actually
read the map, because, and then if
you read Chinese, you'll understand
the ... system, which is based on the
Sanskrit system, the Gedney boxes are
based on the Sanskrit system and believe
it or not even, um, non tonal languages,
like Khmer, but Khmer  changes the
vowelss based on these same categories.
And so if you looked at it then,
well, it's only the pitch that's not
being affected, but the vowel just
like it is in Vietnamese or Thai, um,
affects the overall consonant with,
with the, with the initial consonant.
So I would say don't focus too much
on pitch, focus on the mechanics
of what's going on in your throat.
Get that right.
And then the tones will start to come
out in the wash, just get yourself
exposed to a lot of the natural language.
Well, I, you know, uh,
this is all new to me.
I'll have to look it up,
but I know nothing about it.
I tend to just listen and wing it.
Well, you know, you
know what else is cool?
Like in my Mindkraft class this past
week, we're also looking at Russian
and Scandinavian languages and the, uh,
...
um, I'm just learning
Russian now, but the.
But you will find that even the, and
so there for Russians listening to
Sanskrit, Russian is almost just like
listening to a dialect of Sanskrit.
I can share some resources with you
and the spelling rules of Russian.
So you've got your, um,
...
so the, the hard marker and the soft,
uh, the soft marker, they map exactly
to where these tones are and the
first two rows of the Sanskrit graph.
So you don't have to
remember individual letters.
All you have to remember is any sound
that comes from the back of the throat
or the palette in this Sanskrit map.
Um, you would never use a soft consonant
with it, that will always come out
as their native, their natural thing.
And they map directly
to the Sanskrit grid.
So learning this five by five grid,
which is a map of the  back of the
throat ...  pallet ... top of the mouth
... teeth ...lips going from back to front.
And then you've got unvoiced aspirated
voiced, voiced aspirated nasal.
That's a five by five grid and it
works across all tonal languages.
And believe it or not, even
the spelling rules of Russian
and other Slavic languages.
Wow.
Very interesting.
And so, you know, I
was in Vietnam briefly.
I tried to learn a bit before I
ran it, but didn't get me very far.
Uh, had no, no success with, with Burmese,
but I wasn't there very long either.
Uh, I guess I'll tonal languages I
just speak Mandarin and Cantonese.
And, uh, um, I, you know, I found
with the Mandarin, what helped me
the most was listening to ... because
the ... performers exaggerate, and
the whole thing about tones to me
was getting into the sort of, you
talked about prosody or the end of the
rhythm of, of a phrase or a sentence.
And if you can sum up, pick up on that,
then, uh, your tones will fall into place.
I don't know any of the rules,
but I did certainly Madden was the
first tone of language I learned.
So I tried to remember which
word was, which tone, which
character was which tone.
But when it, when I went into Cantonese,
I didn't bother with that at all.
I just, I just listened to it.
Someone said that there's nine tones
in Cantonese and you know,  the
theory...like all Asian, not, I shouldn't
say all, but a lot of people, speakers
of Asian languages, like to, and not
just Asian languages, people like to
pretend that their own language is the
most difficult language in the world.
So, and then, you know, Poles say
that their language is most difficult.
Like everybody believes their
language is the most difficult.
And, uh, and the Cantonese, oh nine tones,
it's so much more difficult than Mandarin.
And then I read a book that said actually
with six tones you, you'll do just fine.
And that is what persuaded me to
learn Cantonese because nine tones
looked like too much work, but six
tones is only two  more than four...
Okay.
So this is, this is other advice that
you say, um, learning tonal languages.
Yup.
Stop counting tones, just like,
oh, like stop counting tones.
They, there are the same amount
of tones in every tonal language.
There's not the same amount of pitches.
And non-tonal language.
Yeah, no, no, but I'm talking
about tones, so they're, but not...
but the pitches might coincide.
So in Cantonese, whereas in Mandarin,
you've got ... this ...number one tone
is actually ... So it's your ... is
also, uh, uh, ... but you had yin and
yang that yin and yang was what I just
mentioned the voiced and unvoiced.
So, so what Cantonese is closer to
the old Chinese where it just splits.
So you've got two registers
originally, you had a high
register and a low vote register.
So you've got ... and then you've
got ... so you've just got a
high register and a low register.
And then ... and the, those other three
ones, so six to nine is basically,
they are different tones if you're
counting actual tone categories.
But what it means is that they're dead.
So, or they're, they're
stopped at the end.
So ... would be counted
as two different tones.
Traditionally, if you're
counting actual tones.
All I know is If I say something
in Cantonese, and my wife is a
native speaker of Cantonese...
yeah.
Uh, if I say something in
context, it comes out not too bad.
Yeah.
If I say two words, I get them
all wrong and she laughs at me.
So, so as long as I can get
them ... whatever, then okay.
That's okay.
But if I had to hit, you
know, ... I don't know.
I haven't a clue, but if, but if I get
it in a sense, It all hangs together.
And even if it's off a little bit,
it's part of that larger whole.
Yep.
And so all the tones come off okay.
So people think, oh gee, ... , you
know, which isn't true.
And I can be better sometimes than
other times, but if you try to
isolate them, I'll get it wrong.
The thing is too, and it's all
what you're using the language for.
There are a number, languages
say like Chinese too.
If you go to China, it's just expected now
that people speak Chinese, even if you've
got a foreign face, it's just expected.
There are other countries where
it's not expected and there are
other countries, um, where there's
very little leniency done for
non-standard version of their language.
Okay.
So Vietnamese is an example of that.
Thai is an example of that.
So even Thai, even if they speak their
dialect from, uh, northeast or the
north or south or wherever, um, when
they come to Bangkok, they will force
themselves to speak central Thai.
And if they don't, there's
almost shame to it.
And so I guess it's this
nationalistic thing too.
Everybody must speak this standard Thai.
And so that rule is then
also applied to foreigners.
So if it's just a little bit off in
Thailand, Thai's will not understand.
You've scared me off learning Thai no.
Scared me off learning Thai
no, but listen, you know what?
I'm going to stop it there.
I think it's been fascinating because
I know so little about those languages
and I certainly haven't gone at it in
a sort of systematic way that you have.
And I think many of my viewers will
be very interested in following
up, whether it be Mindkraft or the
other, uh, you know, links that
we are leaving in the description.
And I'm sure we could go on
talking for a long time on this.
It is quite interesting.
I am going to look into it because it's,
it's quite fascinating and, and it's a big
part of the world and we're talking well,
China, of course, 1.5 billion people.
But Southeast Asia, Indonesia, South
Asia, we're talking about half the world.
So well-worth all of us learning
more about, so thank you very much.
It's been very interesting.
Thank you Steve.
And I am going to follow up.
Okay.
Bye-bye.